Speaker 1: One of the biggest flashpoints
in the 2016 presidential election came around
records, records, retention emails, email
servers, responsibility with classified and
sensitive information all directed at Hillary
Clinton.
Remember that this was the biggest storyline
about Hillary Clinton.
She would be in jail, Trump said.
If I was president because of what she did
with emails and documents and so on and so
forth every day.
Now I'm not exaggerating.
Every day, just over the weekend, each day
there was another major story about the Trump
White House and records.
And we have we are going to look at two of
those stories now.
And the first is that essentially a raid took
place on Mar a Lago, where the National Archives
showed up to get Trump's documents, many of
which related to meetings with North Korean
dictator Kim Jong UN.
Remember those love letters?
Remember, Trump said when we fell in love?
Trump did not turn over the records to the
National Archives.
He took them to Mar a Lago, and the National
Archives had to go down there and get the
records.
This is an incredible story.
Washington Post reporters Jacqueline Alemany,
Josh Dawsey and others reporting President
Trump improperly removed multiple boxes from
the White House that were retrieved by the
National Archives last month from his Mar
a Lago residence.
He just took the documents home.
Because they contain documents and other items
that should have been turned over to the agency,
according to three people familiar with the
visit.
The recovery of the boxes from Trump's Florida
resort raises new concerns about his adherence
to the Presidential Records Act, which requires
the preservation of memos, letters, notes,
emails, faxes and other written communications
related to a president's official duties.
Trump advisers deny any nefarious intent,
of course, and say the boxes contain mementos,
gifts, letters from world leaders who could
not realize that those are presidential records
and other correspondence.
The items included correspondence with North
Korean leader Kim Jong UN, which Trump once
described as love letters.
Speaker 2: And then we fell in love.
Right, right.
Speaker 1: As well as a letter left for his
successor by President Barack Obama, according
to two people familiar with the contents.
Discussions between the archives and the former
president's lawyers that began last year resulted
in the transfer of the records in January.
Another person familiar with the materials
said Trump advisers discussed what had to
be returned in December.
People familiar with the transfer spoke on
the condition of anonymity.
So in December, they explained to Trump what
needed to be returned, and it took the National
Archives showing up later to actually get
the stuff.
The archives have struggled to cope with a
president who flouted.
There it is, guys.
See, I told you it's a real word.
People always say when I say, Flouted David,
don't you mean flaunt it?
And I say no, I mean flouted.
A president who flouted document retention
requirements and frequently ripped up official
documents, leaving hundreds of pages taped
back together.
So this is this story, and we're going to
talk about the incineration of documents in
a moment.
This is the prototypical backwards projection
scam that was this entire presidency.
The story in 2016 was Hillary's going to do
bad stuff with records.
Hillary can't be trusted with email documents
classified, secret sensitive and since Trump
has left.
We found out that the real concern around
all of those things was Donald Trump and his
kids and other people that worked for him.
Do we think Hillary would have eaten documents
as Donald Trump allegedly did?
No.
Do we think Hillary would have ripped documents
and tossed them onto the floor and then people
run in and grab the scraps and tape them back
together?
Of course not.
Do we think Hillary would have taken documents
about foreign policy meetings and letters
from foreign leaders to her house?
Give me a break, guys, and we can argue about
anything else about Hillary versus Trump.
That's fine.
But on this issue, which was the flash point
about why Hillary can't be trusted, Trump's
the guy that we need to worry about.
I would love to hear more about the retrieval
that took place.
And this is not the only story about Trump
and White House records that
we
have today.